I stay yeah but it was just oh my God
the dog okay tonight I'll get you a real
room all right oh my God a real room you
me a real room you me room at the Hilton
I'll do that will you i' love the you
you might get kicked out I won't get
kicked out I swear I'll be good I'll be
good I'll be good I'll be good I'll be
good no get me the room get me the room
please Hilton trackers Hilt and trackers
is not far from here I'll be really good
I won't smoke in the room or anything I
just haven't been in Hilt in a while I
said at the Miyaki you know one in in
Little Tokyo it was just really weird
it's like $2,000 Hotel it's [__] who
put you up there huh oh I met like a a
random artist woman I was walking around
and I asked her for a cigarette and she
she asked to buy me food I was like yeah
of course and she works like she's she
works with a famous artist she's his
wife of her she you don't know who I am
I'm like no I don't like I know art
people too so it was really weird she
was a crazy [__] Latino woman I don't
know if she was on drugs but like the
second got on the elevator she started
like like she couldn't press the button
she was afraid to press the button and
she kept being like and then she she was
like really like she came into my room
when I was like sleeping like petted me
like a mother you women are really
insecure about that so you I mean the
mommy gears thing I always get women
like that for some reason like sounds
nice sensible chubby sort of women you
know what I mean who have no love in
their life just before I left Egypt I
lived in my shrink for a bit like after
I told you I was in a hospital for a bit
like for rehab and all that and U my dad
would only let me leave if if like I had
an adult supervisor me so I lived over
and she was the creepiest woman ever she
was like oh my God can I bathe you I'm
like what [__] I was like I'm just I'm
just here cuz you know I'm just here so
I don't get fine I'm just here have a
place to live just come up to my room
like oh honey can we cuddle and watch
Cinderella I'm like Cinderella [__]
like the [__] I'm sure L Von show she
was like what is that I'm like huh I
like do you know Kate M say it's always
about Kate M I like do you know Kate M
she's like no I'm like what the [__]
how'd you go through life not knowing K
MK
Ultra MK Ultra it's not MK
Ultra heard there was a Ultra marry Kate
yeah when I think of Kate I think of
witch I know she's a witch but you know
but like she doesn't publicize that's
why she's so private you know what I
mean she doesn't have lot like celebrity
photos of her like no me can't well does
more like kind of like Temple stuff you
know what I mean or like I don't like oh
my god oh oh black C thank God was a dog
comes up on this hello how are you it's
me subing a teenageer [__] very
friendly cat see I think it's my thing
that I never really had like like
Hollywood like you know like a teenager
kind of you know I mean like 16 candles
or share hor with I didn't get that you
know I was a very weird kid I very
insecure and like irritating and like I
called my friends I had no friends so I
feel like I overcompensate for that now
even I'm still a with no friends nobody
loves me Mark people love you like I'd
love to meet these fans Mark I'm allone
well you got you got to stay put and be
like beware where are they come to me
come to me come to me darling I'm here
I'm here in Downtown LA here's here's
what you here's what here's I'm going to
try to get you on board to to either do
a bunch of videos with me and you're
going to create a a little following of
your own and then you you go off and do
your own thing I'm ready for my closeup
Mark I'm ready for my closeup you ready
yes ready to enter the system ready to
have a hunger the only agent I'm ready
problem is you're going to have to show
up I will do all the rituals I will do
all the the Press I love press I love
press press press press I love press
like interviews you know what I mean I
don't like watching that [__] but like I
will talk about I mean like this video
right here this will probably get this
is press yeah this this get50 or 100,000
views extra [__] you know what I mean or
like Letterman which I don't understand
like Letterman like what's the appeal to
a man who looks like that he's really aw
so so where where have you been for the
last two two months two and a half
months oh I told you why no but you
didn't really tell me no I I'm not go in
detail about it cuz it's not like that
important but honestly it was just like
at a battered like women's shelter for
how long for like literally it was like
it was called a crtp a crisis
residential Therapy Program I was just
there for a month can you talk a little
I was a crtp it's a crisis residential
Therapy Program so you got accosted on
the street yeah it's it doesn't matter
I'm fine I'm okay I'm okay it wasn't
aost it on the street it was someone I
knew too if it was like like that I'm in
a l i love that you know what I mean
like rough sux like rough sux guy comes
up and tries to follow me I'm like
please got to go for it you know what I
mean my favorite my favorite line when
I'm [__] is please rape the [__] out
of me like I I'm in a that you know what
I mean I like to [__] like a hardcore SE
it's not like SNM like cuz it's like a
lot of [__] involved you know like like
you're doing stuff like with me with me
like okay but what am I getting out of
this you just like it rough I like it
rough like to [__] like to make love I
don't like to have sex
yeah yeah I think a lot more people like
that than than we I love to meet these
people because honestly all the dudes I
got just really like oh my God like oh
you're so you're so beautiful I'm like I
got it I got it okay I got it I live a
shitty life and you feel the need to
[__] make me feel good about myself
can just get on with the action oh oh
can I can I pet your hair people try to
pet my hair like it's like it's like
it's like I'm a target for grooming or
like the type of dude who would groom
you know what I mean and just cuz I'm
like a nice person so I give off this
kind of like Vibe of you know what I
mean where it's like o you know oh love
me love me say that you like no no D
just just put it in me just put it in me
like the few times that I have had sex
on the street it's been like a very
urgent like kind of transaction like
please please just please just [__] me
it's been ages no one wants to touch me
I'm a disgusting Monster please please
love my body do you like the dress I got
you I love the dress you got me thank
you Mark you get it I love it show it
off huh show it off show it off sitting
down and my body is killing me my black
is dead I what is that Cory gave me
yesterday but like I'm pretty sure it
was like Croc smack and some battery
aome is all over again morning the drugs
aren't the same as they used to be are
they the drugs aren the same they used
to be and it's not hard to [__] get
clean methods just I don't get why
people here want to cut it with [__]
like baby powder and stuff and when you
smoke it it burns so it does stuff to
your bloodstream right where it's like
coagulates your bloodstream and that's
where a lot like your muscles so you get
like muscle spasms like you know when
you do Molly and you grind your teeth I
don't but okay you've never done Molly
I've never done it why not Mark I
haven't done anything but it's weird you
were like kind of like an 80s diletant
you know what I mean like from from what
I GA even though we rarely speak about
you Mark we never speak about you you
feel such a terrible person ever
speaking about you but you seem kind of
dude who like listen to like radio head
but you know maybe the semester like
kind of you know what I mean like I
don't say College radio but like Niche
radio those people always exp drugs have
you smoked a joint in your life never
we're in California how long have you
live here I grew up in Chicago but that
that does that doesn't change anything
that's what I mean like I don't even you
grw up bothy but you certain grew up
were your parents like well
mannered my dad's hardworking my mom was
too exactly normal very normal I mean
European but normal European is in um my
mom was open or
intellectual open what is open open is
like you know your mom tells you about
the you know what I mean like talks
about your sex life or like no no no you
know what I mean no you you got like Tak
not Tak but like extreme Europeans
intense Europeans not not extreme in any
way and there intellectual Europeans you
know like Watch Sunday news you know
what I meanc defin definitely not that
yeah just really good parents did you
have a good Toler great I think it was
pretty great especially my mom side good
for you as was worried about that you
know what I mean cuz you have so much
empathy or such a need to want to be
polite to people in front of you that
usually comes from a place of either
like a good Midwestern boy who's like
been raised well which doesn't happen
anymore doesn't happen thank God that's
pretty much me on those boys you know no
but you like you got hot you know what I
mean you have like a I don't say like a
daddy appeal to you but can you not put
your left hand over the microphone I'm
so sorry thank you I'm a mess today I'm
always a mess I'm it's the meth a hot
mess it's the mess
putting the meth in meth there's a queen
A's drug queen and her name was Crystal
Method I was wonder if she just [__]
named herself that so she could get
drugs for free on the show I wonder how
they got drug sneaked
in I doing porn Mark your nipp your
nipples are showing you're going to get
in trouble I'm going to get in trouble
like I got in trouble I don't have TS
I'm a dude I'm a man I like to [__] I
like to eat isn't that isn't that weird
that I did a video of of a 13-year-old
prostitute and she she had a a bikini
top that I didn't even I wasn't even
aware that you could see through it oh
really like I'm not a breast man so I'm
not really looking at her breast but
what do you like in a woman's body the
shape of her waist and hips and all that
yeah legs so you like more like like
curved kind of long like T tall and thin
with nice curves tall thing but nice
curves yeah which is not the easiest mix
to get no it's hard it's really what's
it say on that to there that say zo or I
see o e what does that say in the red
but so so this video I post it's a cat
oh thank God posted a video yeah and you
could apparently see her nipples I never
noticed but the the the people got so
upset and they couldn't even hear her
story mhm so your nipples are going to
cause controversy no your nipples won't
be any problem no one's going to scream
that we can see Rebecca's nipples but
this girl's nipples were yeah cuz I'm I
had to turn off the comments cuz they
got so bad my nipples are not sacred to
anything I don't have a baby feed it's
not fair I don't have a man pleas I
don't care I don't like when dud play
with my
nipples like it's it's just weird to me
you know what I mean it's like I bite on
like I get really affectionate about D I
like D chess but when it's like comes my
like don't touch me what kind what kind
of what what's your thing muscular oh H
I like muscular dud like rough Stacks I
like hot muscle boys like kind of chubby
boys I don't like skinny boys I hate
skinny boys I like rough sucks I like
someone who knows how to not just take
charge when you're [__] like I want
to feel you on me you know what I mean
don't just shove it in my hole it's like
it's just a hole what am I getting out
of it you know I'm a strict bottom I
don't get putting my penis and things
that's what I mean like we me penis we
have a very weird relationship we're
very detached we definitely it comes
from the other side of my family I don't
know it's like I just don't feel it you
know what I mean like I've had guys blow
me before and I'm just sitting there
like okay are you done like are you
getting something out of this cuz I'm
not getting anything out of it which I I
heard is not common for when you were a
teenager you were in Egypt in Cairo uh
yeah yeah and and being a lot of trouble
cuz I lost in virginity when I was 14
which is like a major thing you what I
got in a lot of trouble for it for what
for losing my virginity my mom I
remember when I lost hilarious story she
started hitting herself she used to beat
me right she's hitting she goes this is
God's anger on our household it's God's
anger on our household just slapping her
face silly for like an hour I'm saying
like [__] what am I going to do about
it like it happened you but being gay as
a teenager in Cairo well of course it
wasn't easy but I mean I grew up more
like upper class you know what I mean so
it's it's understood you know it's not
it's not like lower classes or whatever
where it's like it's just it just
doesn't exist it's just very frowned
upon like I I I had a few gay friends
you know like it's more like a
Cosmopolitan Society so it's understood
but it's just kept to yourself you know
that's what I like about it honestly
it's like who your [__] kind of
doesn't need to matter you know people
make such a big deal about everybody
makes a big deal about it oh you're gay
oh my god oh you're this oh you're my
pronouns my pronouns I'm like dude you
still got a dick don't you some call D
like okay I'm a dude it's like oh let me
waste all my timeing let's Lobby s it
i'm like [__] Kim there's people that
are dying you seen episode of Kardashian
Kim her diam Kim there's people that are
dying people that are dying Kim you
don't
care and it's always like it's either
like women who don't have like you know
what I mean who who have like gay
friends you know what I mean or
something it's like an empathy thing he
just go really h on it I'm like good for
you [__] like what would you know you
know what I mean your hand is over the
mic again oh I'm sorry clutching my
heart said I'm going to
die well I missed you you were gone I
missed you baby for months I love you
baby I I didn't know if you were in jail
or or in the hospital or deported or
what or
dead I didn't know you're back to the
death rumors thank you for getting my
name out there people thank you for
caring about # Rebecca is
alive has beyond belief
hash the
twins it's two t and O people love you
now are they the Antichrist Mark do you
think so that's what happens people come
on my channel like like the Whitakers or
like Rebecca or like the Whitakers where
the Whitakers or Johnny or whatever they
they I'd love to meet these people some
of them seem really interesting love
people have suggested I take you to West
Virginia and introduce you to the
Whitakers I keep L Falls I really I'm
trying to get in with the CIA Mark I
don't think I can get you on an
airplane you can't get me on an airplane
Mar I don't know why you think my
behavior is so socially unacceptable
it's just that I'm dirty you know what I
mean like if I I swear I know how to
behave in society Mark I I I like I meet
people you know what I mean people in
the artw people in the fashion world
it's just that lately like I'm something
that happened in my life where I'm just
like literally just on the street what
what I what I've been people ask me like
where's Rebecca and let me explain
something I could have Mary Kate and
Ashley and Madonna here at my studio at
10 a.m. tomorrow with a winning lottery
ticket for Rebecca all you got to do is
show up at 10: a.m. MH you won't be here
I will be here
Ashley you say you will but you won't
Mark I love you and everything but it's
like I wasn't really sure when we first
started especially when we first started
I didn't know what days you were here I
was here every day yeah I know but I
didn't know that Mark and I was like
literally just downtown you know what I
mean busking for change but it's so hard
for me to walk because like my health is
just dead you know what I mean I'm
telling you urg situation I know it's
it's a thing again it's fine I'm not
complaining today Mark I'm trying to be
a professional look at look at the state
of them oh my God I got cuts and bruises
on them now oh [__] your feet are very
dirty sometimes I'm rubbing them I try
to make words out of like like little
letter spellings or whatever it's like a
game I play let see what I got uh
rib
rise
uh PR
party
be babies
busy and last one will
be it's a b heart and an R heart no but
but but back to what we were just
talking about I think there's potential
for you that's the
cat I think there's potential for you to
create a life yes there is with this
little notori with it this I love they
talking about it Mark but I'm I'm a
woman of action that's why I'm so hard
to pin down because I'm doing things you
know I mean I don't like to sit around
and talk and you know what I mean and
negotiations and blah blah I'm like you
want me to do it I'll do it I swear I'm
that [__] you don't know me like that
yet we haven't been engaged in a
professional man and every time I'm in
here it's literally just me on the side
of the road just being like I'm
desperate for cash and I run into you
and I'm like oh my God Mark Mark my
money Mark with conversation yeah yeah
no but I I I'm I work every day and any
day you want to do this you get together
with me we'll start posting this people
love your talks the more I post them the
more more views they get it seems on
your forehead I see the word I don't
know if it's cuz I'm high but I see the
word m which is eat in French like
etched in your etched in my forehead
etched in your forehead yeah you you
have lipstick etched in your for oh oh
it's the cat [__] it's the cat traa mind
control Market it's trauma mind control
no but I'm saying you you potential to
build build a life that c where you can
actually make money taking advantage of
me Mark they brought me out here you
want me to exploit you and then they're
exploiting me Mark I'm exploited by the
CIA no I'm I'm talking about on social
media I don't have any social media we
can make you a star I wish I could get
exploited wish someone knew who I was I
mean like when I'm when I'm in people
say I'm exploiting you I might as well
exploit you please exploit me please
please I'm here to be fled I sing I can
dance I can do it all let's let's let's
woman of the night no but you you could
take that ball and run with it and then
you do your own thing I can be civilized
mark my you can be a star I will be a
star I'm not worried I mean people are
becoming stars on social media rather
people are boring to be a star I'm a
star [__] like I know Hollywood I know
the industry I I know how it works
because I come from a mindset of like
the old days of it you know what I mean
agents and picture and like projects
it's not like today where it's like
these shitty [__] what happened to
Art House Cinema chlo SV you know what I
mean like that whole wave oh my God
relax might be those demons that are
trying to get me or black cat the black
cat the black cat curious and curious
here's my broadcast called black hatat I
used to hate it when I was a kid cuz I
what's your what's your favorite song
this week my favorite song this week
honestly uh probably
be my lover remember that song be my be
my lover put your hands up for Detroit
um par song that's a hot one um ride a
white horse which I was playing on the
back
FR ride a white horse people love your
musical
taste is a drag and people don't know
this but there's a phenomenon in
witchcraft or in ancient witcraft we to
drve women in tar it's not written about
I don't always talk about the stone
stone age but yeah like drag that's
where the word drag queen comes from
because these men would there was a
subset of society in the good old days
who would go out of their way to insult
and deprecate women That's the basis of
modern feminism you know but it's like
it was like a torturous thing you know I
me it's just they didn't have like
history books in the Medieval ages but I
I went into it and I met with like
experts and stuff for like just general
conversations see I'm seen the word
famous faker
and Manner and reveal or reveil on that
oh my godess I don't know what Cory gave
me last night you need sleep I don't
need sleep I need like society and
interaction and showers and [__]
green juices and thought life you know
what I mean I need a I need a goop scoop
to loop I need that good old [__]
California sunshine you go back to the
beach you go back to swimming I haven't
been in water in so long look rich of
East water's too cold right now yeah I
hate cold water I hate cold water yeah I
got punched in the face and [__] take
a bath I can't do it like someone throws
water at me I'm like oh my God it's
happening a few times out here you know
which just adds to my [__] it appeals
a witch you know makes feel more of a
witch get water thr it's ironic isn't it
burn the witch the Witch Is Dead just
bring me back her head Medusa
Medusa versat you like they don't they
don't do it right you know what I mean
there's like something missing where
it's like where it's like pushed like
you can show up Versace in Greek you
know I mean especially Medusa well
Medusa has nothing to do with vanity
that's more Aphrodite gig Medusa is very
controversial cuz she was a demigod but
she was like a really evil woman and
with the snakes in her head and stuff
and she was one of the rare goddesses in
ancient history that had an ugly
attribute and was known for it and
exploited it and obsessed with Medusa
she she um mirrors Cleopatra where
Cleopatra used her vanity in a positive
way but still a very Wicked Woman like
all witchcraft comes from Cleopatra
Medusa wasn't a witch she was a goddess
she was a demig godess she was a monster
like ggan you know what I mean her mom
chopped her hat off and had her
delivered her on a silver plate Rachel
I'm waiting for you right
here Rachel and Rebecca met at the bar
they knew they were going to go real far
they were doing lines in the toilet all
of a sudden in walks Kell Luts from that
show I know no he's trying to get where
R short Rebecca was like can I get in on
the action Kell was like I don't know
can you handle it can you handle it but
then we were back at the bar we ordered
some Cosmos and started getting popular
with all the people out of the club when
you go when you go to West Hollywood do
you get into the clubs or they don't let
me in because I don't have ID I keep
saying this I'm an illegal I don't have
I just need identification I can get a
job I get a [__] you knowu anything
with that identification housing all
that [__] you know what I mean we get
you an ID okay can we get me an ID thank
you that's all I need all I ask of you
Mar is return you just
decided but you might have to put some
clothes on some clothes on yes this is
your styl Mar this is your draws you
have a shoe you have two shoes I have
two shoes yeah you have two shoes I have
two shoes one for the parties and one
for the clubs I got two shoes one for
the Raves and one for dir Fe I can't
remember I went out to a dinner you know
what I mean like a civilized [__]
dinner when I was in New York I always
used to go out for dinner you know what
I mean one thing cuz I wasn't really
doing drugs at the time like I was like
recreationally but like so I'd go to
like Boule or I'd go to [__]
my favorite was bar prie on the bar CU I
lived on the B Bar pry was amazing or
like the beach just in or I left in
madis park you know what I mean and like
go out have a civilized meal it's like
30 40 bucks but you feel like a [__]
you know cosmopol you feel like a real
person you know digify human be La don't
doesn't have that there's no fine dining
it's like like the but you prefer LA to
New York it's just easier for me here
honestly cuz it's like Chiller it's like
it's not as [__] scatter it's not as
huge I can't deal with all that [__]
like oh my god there so much going on
all these people in the street it just
irritates the [__] I'm hear empty it's
like there's a there's there's a feeling
of Solace you go to the beach it's
aboundant which is really weird to me
considering La is the center of modern
culture in our globe all of the no
foreign films America accounts for all
the foreign propaganda all
behavioral constants I live by the be
it's overrated American but it's not
overrated Mark no you don't like in
other countries cuz I grew up outside of
America that's all you have so it's
weird that that they have that Lev of
influence globally but when it comes
when I came to Al I was like it's not as
recognized here like it's it's still
very like I don't know like being
American is a is a thing like from where
I up we're like oh my God America oh you
you went to America oh you're oh you
know what I mean like it's it's it's
like it's like you're a God you know
what I it's like it's it's just it's
something else you know like even when
we go to Paris or we go to [__] Milan
or you know we go to be or like Lebanon
that's chill but oh America you know
what I mean there's such a thing with
America it's like there's that one Robin
Williams movie where the Russians came
to buy blue jeans or
whatever
jeans white shirt I love long [__]
mess you know I miss I just cour you
love what happened what didn't happen to
get so they just they just fall off the
gr I show a picture she she wore she
wore a sh she was she wore a shirt that
read eat my on I'm like try harder eat
my ass one of the greatest albums ever
was yeah uh yeah yeah whole Li with us
violet violet yeah I forget the name of
it yeah play you can play Violet I love
Violet everyone one one of the one
of was
amazing and all the stars were just like
for she she had a real thing going on
with with Nirvana it was more just like
it's like an indie [__] oh I do hear
and hear my lyrics you know it's just
but with with Courtney there's something
behind it you know I mean there's like a
raw like an
aggression like when we really go for it
you know what I mean yeah very few women
can very few women can do that yeah oh
my God can't stopped chill bro chill so
one thing I get with animals especially
when I pet them there's like
a anyway but yeah to the perspective
clients Rebecca Olsen can offer services
in manipulation attraction devotion
character study persuasion styling
modeling acting and of course the art of
civilized conversation for consideration
Rebecca ol do Celebrity Skin Celebrity
Skin oh yeah yeah that one's oh make me
over incredible that one's like cute for
me cuz it's like you know what I mean
it's like it's like a get up and get
ready song you know I like I like um um
what's that line where it's like uh but
I'm not selling she but I'm not selling
she I can't can't remember but every
song on that record is incredible show
Daria I just think that she sang it
sounds like saying this the sound the
the theme song for that show Dar
remember I was on MTV you might not know
about it it's like ' 90s I don't it's a
cartoon show oh my God it's like the
most incredible thing that's ever
happened on TV what's it called Daria
it's literally she's like this very meta
very
like benol but kind of it was a spin-off
of ab and but but it's not Butthead it's
like the only character that you get
that's like a fully fleshed out
intellectual character without being
like something with smart people I
realize this it's like why why go out
here be like Oh I'm a smart person look
at my problems cuz I'm smart like why do
all intellect right I have to come from
a place of like not enjoying life like
look at me be serious like it's okay to
be smart and want to love make money you
know what I mean like people who who got
make money like people who work in
finance you know what I mean to me those
are geniuses you know work hard play
hard
they're they never looked upon as you
know it's always like oh that guy's in
finance or whatever oh that bro it's
like [__] him but it's like dude that
guy makes a [__] ton of money like
that's smart to me to me like that gr a
thumb break you're going oo the ice cops
are melting look at me I'm a 14-year-old
child and the ice cops are melting good
for you [__] you know get get a life
get a [__] I don't know like I love I
love honey booo you know what I mean
that's that's like [__] that has
Charisma to it you know like I have the
same sensibility is D reand like I can
pull from anyone from high to low you
know what I mean but with real class you
know what I mean real class eares us
like none of those house even bothered
to do it which is weird they State it's
like very one note just like hi I am a
middle-aged woman and here's me with my
friends and we're kind of going to get
an argument about it but it's not that
the only one who really went for it was
Lisa Rena and I love her it was very
weird with her because it's like she she
actually was like a star and the role
was kind of seen at first as her kind of
like belittling herself it's like it's I
don't think it's beneath her but you
know what I mean but she really went for
like I've never seen a woman just enjoy
her life you know especially I guess I I
mean I haven't really lived that life
but when you start out in the industry
it's like very difficult for you because
you have to be on point you know what I
mean like she did Roxy on Broadway and
she did Melrose Place and people don't
think about that life but like you're
having to study lines you're having to
do 6 a.m. call times it's hard for women
it's not just that it's hard for women I
honestly think it's easier for women
because with a woman it's you're given a
role as sensuous it's it's an easier
role with men it's taken more seriously
like which I find really irritating when
D like oh my craft like [__] you dude
seen d movie it's done Tom Hanks you
like good for you I a serious man look
at my look at my life of oh my wife and
the only guy I like is coming to Spacey
cuz with him there's like a humor you
know what I mean yeah okay so he [__]
them youve been high and rubbed up on a
dude that Scandal Harvey Weinstein oh
you gave Harvey Weinstein a blow drop
got the movie yeah you did oh he he did
he you no no no no real [__] though real
[__] though you didn't suck his dick for
a part you didn't suck his dick to an
Oscar suck his dick an Oscar she never
said anything I didn't come up at the
time interesting it's called Johansson
yeah yeah you have a blow drob which is
weird too because she's like a skinny
girl she doesn't eat like a free in
Ghost World which one of my favorite
like Americana movies of all time she
she went got her tits on you know like
oh you're going to go get your suck
Harvey wiste off the [__] yeah do I
remember she she was in those do perfume
she couldn't understand she not a
fashion person and she wore Mar at
The Who that guy you're talking to on
the phone when I met you who does
spanking professional spanking cuz I'd
be interested in doing that when I when
we first met and being spanked yeah I
don't think I ever interviewed him he
was in New York oh yeah I know but I
heard you talking to him on the phone I
was intrigued yeah yeah once I I do
those kind of talks sometimes come up
with like a technos song people into
weird interesting stuff I thought it
would be like you see do like a kind of
like a fleshy kind of Goo Dolls kind of
techno like Benny bosi beat to just the
word spank there's a couple there's a
couple interview subjects that I'm try
they're very elusive elusive yeah I'm
trying to find a woman who started with
a pen pal relationship with a guy in
prison and and the getting into a
romantic relationship with him yeah that
happens often in Mar that happens a lot
but getting to talk about it has been oh
my God oh my God it's a cat yeah I
know look my father is a devil that's
surprising many a
time like I'm not like a fan girl but
when someone does something it is
important to give it its space who would
you like to give H who would you like to
give uh respect to right now right now
kissy Cal Walder Marina abovich
Cindy
Sherman of course Mary Kate and Ashley
Nicole Kidman Nikki
Hilton I know I like the idea of a muse
and an icon and all that all women yeah
like that idea doesn't exist
as fluently as it used to like in the
old time like I don't say old times but
like even in even in popular Cinema a
director would have his Muse we turn off
the music please sorry it's not that
loud I know but it's gonna I'm sorry
just like their computers for picking up
this stuff are
sensitive you can't hear Mark you don't
have a headset in your head you don't
have a government chip implant no
YouTube picks up on all this like
background music when I'm at Walmart or
wherever doing a you go to Walmart you
go to Walmart no I took the Whitaker
family to Walmart in West Virginia oh
you do how civilized are you took
Christmas shopping I don't like how
Walmart looks like it's just it's like
intentionally you you don't seem like a
Walmart Shopper it's not that I'm not a
Walmart Shopper is more of a Target
shopper cuz Target it's just presented
like what was the the restaurant you
said you actually liked chilies or
Murray calendars I love
chilies [__] I will [__] up at Chili's
CU I grew up with the mozzarella sticks
cuz I don't know if you have them here
but in CYO they had mozzarella sticks
and they're like the crazy they just
taste so good it was like cut like an
orgas in my mouth and people say that
like like their ultimate food memory you
come from Paris and New York and Paris
and New York and Chili's yeah yeah no
like especially in Paris like I don't
like the food's just overhyped even
French people it's like French cuisine
I'm like dude it's just it's just you
know
snails like yeah is Paris overrated
Paris is not overrated no no no no Paris
will be Paris forever Paris is Paris
forever I love Paris more than anything
I love Paris I love Paris as a Parisian
that's why I always tell people from
Paris cuz it just makes sense to me know
I mean to say it you know people always
think I'm like trying to put on AR but
I'm like no no cuz Paris is cool like
when you get into Paris Paris is like
the epicenter of cool I agree but it's
not just cool it's like intellectual
refinement it's like people are
intelligent there but they're not smart
it's not like the [__] Big Bang
Theory [__] I [__] can't not that
[__] like you don't have to be ugly and
decrepit to know things you know what I
mean cuz no one would [__] you or take
you out to prom so you're busy studying
your [__] physic textbook [__]
your physics textbook you know what I
mean like good for you you know I
mean like I like an underdog and all
that but honestly Coming of Age all that
what's your favorite city in Europe
Paris Paris and then Moscow but I've
never been to Moscow Ive been to Berlin
right hm you been to Berlin I haven't
been to Berlin you haven't no it seems
like I would have gone to Berlin but it
just never crossed lo my mind I know
that it's more an artc scene I've always
wanted to go to Berg which is a club
they have there which is like supposedly
notoriously difficult to get into I've
never how to trouble getting into a club
cuz of the way I dress you know you been
to London huh oh yeah when I when I was
in London yeah but I didn't go to clubs
cuz I was way too young and I didn't
know I didn't have enough money to get a
fake ID I was only at boarding school
for a year but I went to like I went to
a club once with like a friend and she
stuck me in but otherwise yeah know and
like I missed out on the Rave scene
which completely blanked me because I
was outside of London my boarding school
was was an hour away from London it was
in the country it was in the town
Charles Dickens grew up in ironically
enough who I hate only thing I hate is
Charles Dickens Charles Dickens John
Steinbeck and [__]
um and Rush limbal the three men I just
can't stand I I don't get it like what's
the appeal you I mean Shakespeare [__]
Shakespeare I like o oo whoa some dude
wrote plays in [__] 1500s oo like why
is he the one player that's like studied
yam Pomer oh so he it was like it's like
you're ready in huz or whatever good for
you you can lay a beat down honey the
stories are just quashed and Bol and
it's all
just like what is it about the need for
an artist to glorify suffering I glorify
like I hate that character study it's
like ooh my father o my daddy didn't
love me enough as a kid and now I
[__] I know like at least with French
Fones you know what I mean especially
with female roles like Isabelle huppert
is probably one of my top actors of all
time one my favorite but I love how she
approaches it because all her roles are
very like I was saying transgressive
like the piano teacher she like the
scene where she cut her clip with a
razor or she [__] her son or my
favorite one is AB abuse of weakness
just the title struck me but literally
she um so she's a director she plays a
director and she reads about a guy on
the news who was like a scammer or
something and SC people on millions of
dollars I want to make a movie about you
and the movie um kind of like documents
their relationship but it's very like
tongue and cheek and he's not trying to
[__] or anything which what I like the
first thing directors go to it's like
ooh but but we're also trying to [__]
it's like okay good people have sex like
sex is really overated in American
movies it's just approach like oo and
here is the love scene here Americans
are very uptight about sex it's not they
upset about sex it's like sex exists I
feel like Americans it's actually well
culturally of course it's the only
[__] country in the world that
accepts kind of like casual sex even
like the Europeans aren't as vulgar
about it as people are here like oh you
go to a bar and get laid like it's
normal here you know it's not like it's
not like you know like you tell your mom
when you lose your virginity you're
saying in Europe that does not happen it
happens but it's just it's not made as
it's not as much of a point you know
what I mean it's like it's more like you
[__] when you're a teenager and then
when you when you get older it's like
whatever you just hook up with people
but here's like sex is a thing like when
they say sex cells I understand why um
like the market so again La it's just
things are done in a very like stoic way
it's almost like Washington you know
like I remember I saw I was watching
what was it random movie but This Means
War it was re and the whole time I'm
like like why are you trying to land
these corny jokes like Reese has so much
potential and so much talent and it was
just such a but you have [__] Reese
with poon Tom Hardy and Chris Pine in a
movie it's a CIA like humor movie and
the whole thing is just like these like
tired gags you know she wants to movie
called how do you know was Jack nson
cost $90 million to make just like a
typical [__] comedy like literally
just like a typical romantic comedy uh
like she's like I think she's also
trying to choose between two dudes
they're like butan cost $90 million to
make cuz they built like a whole [__]
studio for it made like $50
million like it just goes down in
distribution right like it's not hard to
movie that's the thing with Reese like
after Legally Blond like it's not that
her movies don't have appeal but she's
kind of like um you say like a girls
girl she produced gong girl though she
us wanted to put herself in the role
sorry I know I'm not talking about she
us wanted to put herself in the role but
um but then they went with rosan Pike
instead which I think was the best
decision they ever made I've never seen
a female role like that in my life to
this day like I'm like I would kill
myself for her like what she did for
me this weird what's weird about people
out here they're so removed from La it's
like I like La people I like Hollywood
people you know what I mean like you go
to any [__] bar [__] Hollywood or
whatever it's weird that that doesn't
exist in downtown I still don't
understand downtown
honestly you don't like La for night
life or you do no I love that life
that's why I don't get it why they don't
have a Like a downtown scene it's weird
cuz like dude even [__] Milwaukee I
seen this before Milwaukee [__]
Wisconsin they have downtown with like
clubs and bars La doesn't really have
it's the place it's the place to be I
mean LA's downtown is like it's New York
has downtown like LA's downtown this
this is I've never seen anything it's
like a human rights violation it's exist
I'm like why are these people in 10wn so
give him a shower it's like it's like I
come to you from Africa to remind you
well there other parts of town that have
a night life that Mak maybe is a more
respectable yeah but they don't have a
night life here there's no night life
why isn't there a single decent Club out
here there's a red line there's a bar
that open it's like a small bar called
Lost plus found there's the [__] uh
what's that mycal place um cuz I always
dce outside there always always always
they love me there they like don't you
come near ha I'm like okay whatever I'll
go down fing around the corner but they
always let me smoke and stuff uh uh
pattern pattern bar yeah that's my
favorite cuz I think of just like life
in La is very different than the way
it's wired in Paris or New York no no
but here it's just it's just again it's
very casual it's almost like everyone's
just like getting off work and wants to
go for drinks wants to go for Mexican
food there isn't like a real hardcore
scene here like there is an underground
but it's not it's not like it was in the
' 90s it's not like the [__] um
what's his name uh gregar rocki and
[__] you know jber like like those
kids even out to party the ' 80s any out
a party you know what I mean like I
remember someone was telling me out here
that Robert down Jor used to come down
here to get us drugs when he was like on
drugs which is really rich like you have
a drug dealer [__] you come down here
like who came down here and lived down
here was it um Aaron Carter this a
subbody who came down here and lived
down here for like 2 weeks cuz he was
like so hopped up on
math it allowed me to overcome the uh
the Pains of my methamphetamine
addiction with seeing Aaron Carter go
through a similar experience to me you
know it's hard for me out he Mark being
homeless drug addicted not
prostitute being a filthy bum it's so
difficult well maybe we'll change that
then let's change that Mar it's about
it's about time let me help you okay I
think it is about time we'll get you
some housing yes we'll get you it's time
to make me starve a stage and screen
time to civilizing but you can't
disappear for a month my fair lady you
can't disappear on me again whatever you
say Mr D I will be your slave no I don't
want you to be my slave I just want you
to be a little tiny bit responsible I
will be I sorry I know I know my na girl
your your whole Persona is about just
doing whatever the [__] you want exactly
but I want you know that a lot of those
times where I'm missing it's it's not as
it's not as like cool as you think it's
just like literally a I'll be in the
hospital because I I I get B to Suicide
or whatever and I that's yeah yeah
that's not cool no but it is easy to
[__] get a free meal no again it's
just being an
immigrant the life of an immigrant see
always always do those stories on the
news I would [__] rock that [__] like
I'm about to get deported I I Googled it
and there was a guy who was literally
had the same [__] story none of the
background none of the [__] panach
just literally was just getting deported
cuz he was like Mexican too and gay and
or like Brazilian or something which
weird cuz that's all out there and he he
got tons of pressed for and I'm like
where's my cross where's my attention
where's my celebrity when is it
Rebecca's
time they may Ashley and Elizabeth
before me I feel I'm over Jew for my
moment in Spotlight it's coming the had
let me help you in 2000s nylon
magazine Mar magazine all right Rebecca
New York minute Elizabeth
olon had her I'm glad you're okay
you look like a Marcy May to me I'll
leave you with without Hollywood my
favorite line ever in cinemon you look
like a Marc May to me for your
consideration [__] Sundown [__]
bunch of hawks I hate Sundowns like
Cinema like kind you know what I mean
like movies like with style and
something going on oh you want to shoot
[__] [__] $5 budget movie I'm
like
that